the original john wickers stood the test
of time as one of the more perfect
modern action movies we've loved the
premise since the first time we heard it
man loses wife man gets dog mobster
kills dog and man violently gets his
revenge on about 90 people the dog is
avenged a new dog is acquired all is
right in the world it's crazy
but then the world expanded john wick
chapter two came along furthering the
story of the vengeful assassin and
ladling out more lore about the circle
of killers in which he used to run maybe
the film posits some people get upset
when their relatives get stomped the
same way that john wick got upset about
his stumped-up dog commenced to more
killing as john wick fights to survive
the wave of shooters coming for him john
and his new dog go on the run with
danger around every corner common gets a
knife stuck in his torso john wick does
joker's trick
truly it doesn't get any better than
this also we thought and then
i'm thinking i'm back
this is the world that viewers can
expect to walk into if they flip on john
wick chapter three para bellum the three
quarters making waves on netflix in
certain international markets right this
minute sorry americans not on your
netflix only other regions it's a world
of action a world of adventure a world
where the exchange rate on giant gold
coins remains bamboozlingly inconsistent
like you can use one to buy a gun but
you can also use one to buy a gin and
tonic and whatever that's not the point
the movie picks up right where chapter 2
left off so john wick has a 14 million
dollar bounty on his head with an hour
to leave the city and a promise that'll
stomp any assassins that tried to take
him out our hero makes a hasty escape
taking a break to fight some guys in an
antique warehouse to keep things
interesting a jet setting adventure is
well underway and wick takes off for
casablanca searching for a higher rub
from the high table basically he wants
to speak to a manager
i'd like to see the manager
of course
meanwhile in new york change is the only
constant and wix old buddies the bowery
king and winston are being forced out of
their positions of power on account of
their having helps the protagonist
there's plenty of blood lots of fights a
horse versus motorcycle battle and heavy
traffic and so on most importantly
thanks to the addition of harley berry's
sophia the dogs finally get a chance to
do some stomping of their own
good to see you too i should shoot you
in the head right now
i know
basically if you're looking for a good
time at the movies and don't mind
watching your heroes slaughtering
roughly a hundred goons john wick
chapter three parabellum might just be
your
i gotta tell you
i've been looking forward to meeting you
for a long time
it is a rare and beautiful thing to find
a movie about a guy who's great at
shooting people that gets near uniformly
glowing reviews john wick chapter 3
parabellum it's that beautiful thing
with a certified fresh critics rating of
89 on rotten tomatoes the third movie in
the saga of john wick is neck and neck
with chapter 2 for the title of best
reviewed film in the franchise the
chicago tribune called it the best of
the three so far the guardian x told
quote fight sequences so balletic you
might forget you're watching violence
until reeves sinks a knife into a man's
eye peter travis of rolling stone in a
4.5 out of 5 star review told hesitant
potential viewers you can wait around
and hope for a bigger badder burst of
action fireworks than john wick 3 but
you'd be kidding yourself all in all
john wick chapter 3 is everything that
fans could hope for in a blockbuster
action sequel it offers the same flavor
of violence being doled out in the first
two films with a considered bump in
intensity and ambition from series
director chad stahlski the worst thing
you can say about the picture is that it
ends with more of a question mark than a
period but like everything else about
the movie that's a choreographed move
john wick chapter 4 is slated to hit
theaters in 2022.
[Music]
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and tv shows are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]